Before we say goodbye,
let's play a quick round of-
Drewth or Dare.
(audience cheer and clap)
Hi, we have Rose Rosato.
Hi, Rose.
Hi.
Hello.
All right, we know it's a dare
because we see this little setup here,
but we do not know what is happening.
Yeah, what are we doing?
Okay, so we're gonna be spicing things
up a little bit today.
Oh gosh.
You're gonna be eating jalapeno peppers,
while you get to know me a little bit.
Oh yeah, by the way, I'm so excited.
You love hot things.
Me, not so much.
Buckle up Rossi.
Okay, look at, oh God, look at those.
These by the way,
that's a sizable pepper I just have to say.
In the pepper world, yes.
Yes.
Good luck.
Okay, oh God.
Hey Rose, so what's your favorite time of day?
Nighttime.
(Ross coughs)
Who's someone you've always admired you sadistic woman?
(audience laugh)
That would have to be my mom.
She came here from Puerto Rico
and was always a strong woman that I admire.
I love that.
I love moms.
I'm not sure about you, but I love your mom.
(Rose and audience laugh)
Do you have any pets?
I do, I have three Chihuahuas
and a cockatoo with a big personality.
Can I finish now?
Do I have to eat the whole thing?
I mean, Drew's doing pretty well.
Can you do it?
Can you finish the whole thing?
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
Oh my God!
(audience cheers and claps)
This is outrageous.
You're not gonna do it.
Are you single?
No.
Do you have a boyfriend, girlfriend?
Which is it?
I have a boyfriend, yes.
What's your proudest accomplishment?
Getting my master's degree.
It was kind of like a thank you back to my parents.
Can I just ask why you made us do this?
So it's funny because I can't handle spicy food
so I just wanna kind of test you guys out.
Yeah, yeah you did great though.
(audience cheers and claps)
This is the only thing left Rose.
Wow, Drew, I can't believe you did that.
(audience claps)
Rose, it's been real pleasure.
Thank you for choosing to spend your time with us.
(audience cheers and claps)
We make this show for you
so take it with you.
(upbeat music)